her it's really really good to see you
my first question is I have no idea who
my graduation speaker was in high school
do you remember yours I don't remember I
remember you know a few teachers a few
speeches that you know we're supposed to
motivate me and we're supposed to make
me feel like okay I got this but I don't
I don't think it was very effective I
think the kids are really lucky that
we'll have you because listen no one
will forget this graduation ceremony and
it's so cool that you are taking part
why was it important for you to be
involved I mean this is Major
I mean it's the least we can do all
these big names I mean the support that
they're giving these kids is really
really dope I mean you need that and
it's unfortunate that we can't all
celebrate together and be in the same
room in the same place celebrating so
it's really important for me to be a
part of this so we all remember what it
was like when we were seniors you know
you're turning a chapter you're going to
another chapter in life in these very
uncertain times what's your message for
seniors who are maybe feeling a little
anxious a little uncertain and certainly
a little unsettled right now I mean the
biggest thing is is the fact that things
don't go always go as planned as you can
see you know we did not expect the
things happening in 2020 the way that
they are happening so I mean the biggest
thing is expect the unexpected and and
you know you can prepare and you can
prepare but sometimes you just have to
to live in the moment sometimes you just
have to go with it and adjust and and be
okay with how things are and be
frustrated and be upset and be sad or be
you know just just just be and and let
things go the way they're supposed to go
everybody hers you know is trying to
find creative ways to pass the time
during this pandemic you know not
everybody is creative as you but I'm
wondering what are you doing to get
through I'm so glad you get to be
hunkered down with your family and loved
ones so what do you what are you doing
yeah I'm happy I'm with my family but
I've been cooking a lot which I never do
since I'm always on the go which is nice
sometimes it's nice to just breathe for
a second I've been writing a lot I'm
still working on my project
and just really calling the people that
I love that I maybe haven't spoke to in
a long time I think I've had the time to
really you know sit and and think about
people and reach out to them so I've
been doing that a lot and yeah just
playing music listening to music doing a
lot of the stuff I I never really had
time to do when can we expect new music
from you I love your stuff oh thank you
soon hopefully you know I've been doing
my live streams and and really great
things like this just to keep it going
and to keep putting music out there so
I'm sure you'll hear something new
really soon
well I can't wait and you're also
working on a project girls with guitars
something else for people to look
forward to from you thank you her
congratulations I know you will kill it
over the weekend I can't wait I'll be
watching thank you